CATHERINE DRENNAN: I really want
the students to feel actively
participating in lectures.
And so the clicker's
definitely help.
I try to space them every five
to seven minutes that there's
a clicker question.
And I know from teaching
this a number of times
now that some of the
clicker questions,
they will-- pretty much all
the students will get right.
And they'll be all
happy and feel good.
And then there are other
ones that I ask on purpose
because I know that these are
questions that the students can
really hang up on on exams.
They're tricky things.
And so I want them
to make the mistake
when it doesn't count
in the clicker questions
so they get it
right on the exam.
And so one thing
that I will do, I'll
often try to get them
to tell-- if they
got it right, explain why.
So that's one
thing I like to do.
And I go around to different
conferences and things
and often will pick up free
pens, or free whatever, rulers,
all sorts of stuff
that people give out.
And so then I say, if
someone-- you know,
and they see that
they've gotten it right.
So that makes them feel a little
more confident before they
speak in front of 350 people.
And said, OK, I have this
awesome little periodic table
ruler thing.
Who can tell me
what the answer is?
And so then I have a TA go
around with a microphone,
and that they say how they
thought about the problem, what
the answer is.
And so just kind of
encourage people to talk.
--ask people to
explain, now that they
know what the right answer
is, if someone will explain
why that is the right answer.
And I know it's a big
class and people sometimes
get nervous about talking,
so I bribe people.
So today the person who
answers why that is correct
will get at an MIT
chemistry t-shirt.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Let's see.
For every-- if you're
using 5 moles of N2,
you need 15 moles
of hydrogen gas.
So since there's not
enough hydrogen gas,
there's only 10 moles, that
means the hydrogen gas should
be the limiting reactant since
you would need roughly 3.33
moles of N2 for it.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Great.
And here is an MIT
chemistry t-shirt.
Other times, if the
clicker question,
you know, it's like
50/50 in the answer,
then I won't tell
them what's right
and ask them to talk to their
neighbor and vote again.
And sometimes I'll also have
them talk to each other,
and then weigh in on something.
And whenever we're
going to do a demo,
I want them to think
about what might happen
and what the possibilities
are, things like that.
And sometimes that will be a
clicker question ahead of time.
And then they're really
ready and engaged
when they see the demo of what
the answer is going to be.
So those are some of the
things that I can do.
Another one of the
fun things that I
like when I'm talking
about the difference
between thermodynamics
and kinetics,
we can talk about how a reaction
might be thermodynamically
favorable, and so, you
know, combustion of sugar--
thermodynamically favorable.
So I'll bring in some candy.
And we do like a demo in class,
and everyone has a candy.
And it's like OK, when
you open it up to oxygen,
there should be CO2 released.
And so then we do the demo
and see that it's actually
a slow reaction.
So we don't see the gas release.
But, you know, ways where
everyone in the class
can have something that
they do a demo with, even
if it's a little bit silly.
Still there is that engagement
then with the material.